PlayStation VR releases this October and
it'll cost you four hundred dollars that
price is certainly lower than
competitors like the oculus rift in the
HTC vive but it might still seem too
good to be true and it sort of is that
four hundred dollars doesn't include the
required camera or optional move
controllers the good news is that a
bundle is on its way in North America
the PlayStation camera retails for 60
bucks and move controllers sell for 50
of course the PS VR headset does work
with a standard dual shock but some
games actually require to move
controllers so it's fortunate that Sony
is releasing a bundle and for the record
Sony didn't include the camera in the
first place because quote many people
already own it the PlayStation VR bundle
is confirmed for North America but we
haven't heard about other territories no
price has been revealed either but
considering PS vr is one of the few
headsets selling at a profit the bundle
shouldn't break the bank for anyone in
the meantime stay tuned to gamespot for
all the latest in playstation news